It is Teacher Appreciation Week,
which is, you know, pretty much should be every week,
especially in this last year.
Absolutely.
We really put our sweet, incredible, innovative,
dedicated, and patient teachers
through the wringer this year.
And actor and friend of the show, Max Greenfield,
he posted this beautiful photo of his little one,
and if that doesn't sum it up, nothing does.
That's Max's son, Ozzie,
and the caption is hashtag teacher appreciation week
thanks Mrs, Patricia.
For the past year, Max has been hilarious,
posting pics of his kid's homeschool journey on Instagram.
He just looks like such a good dad.
Does this sum up what it felt like for you
with your kids when they're homeschooled?
No, this is way too sweet.
(Ross laughs)
There were no images for what it was like in my house.
Yeah?
Yeah, fire, flames, cats.
(cat's sound)
So, it was fun.
And thanks to all the teachers
and thanks, Max for posting that pic 'cause LOL.
All right, next, we got some huge green news
from the happiest place on earth that got a little happier.
People reports that Disney parks are going solar.
Sound goofy?
Well, look at these stats.
In Orlando, within the next two years,
solar facilities will power 40% of Walt Disney World.
And at an Anaheim, Disneyland has already installed
1400 solar panels.
And over in France, Disneyland Paris,
they built huge solar canopies to generate power
while shading 9,500 cars in the parking lot.
And they say all their global efforts together
could power eight Magic Kingdoms.
My question is how much sun power does it make
to spin a tea cup and make those churros that I zone in on
whenever I go to Disneyland?
I loves me a churro.
But I love that the solar panels
are in the shape of the mouse.
Yeah, cute.
Whoever thought of that idea, just chef's kiss.
And thank you, Disneyland, in general, once again,
for showing the power of a corporate example
of how we need to proceed into our future
so that we may have one.
Absolutely.
So thank you, Disney, thank you, thank you, thank you.
We also have some news for the hopeful singles out there.
I was actually talking about this
with Vanessa Hudgens earlier,
and how she was saying dating apps is kind of so photo first
and that's not everyone's approach.
it's definitely not mine.
And Tinder has got this brand new feature,
I'm so excited about it.
Mashable reports that Vibes is an app feature
designed to help users get better matches.
So it quizzes you on different types of pop culture
and personality questions to get a better feel
for how you vibe and match up to others.
For example, here's one.
Are you a 20 minutes early
or a 10 minutes late kind of person?
I would have to put 20 minutes early because you know-
(crew laugh)
(Ross laughs)
(Drew laughs)
I'm working on it, I'm working it.
It's gotten so much better this year.
Can you imagine how bad it used to be?
I'm working on it.
This is great because like,
it's a way to sort of get to know somebody,
like you said, more than a picture and a swipe, right?
You know, for some people,
like a ten minutes late kind of person.
Mm-hm.
Could be such a deal breaker
for a twenty minute early type of person.
Totally.
That being said, I do wonder, and we talked about this,
do they also think that opposites can attract.
Like if you're into sports,
and you're into the arts, that's great,
like you can do museums and baseball games.
Like so I'm just curious about all of it,
but I'm so excited about these little features
that give just more insight than a darn photo.
Yeah, because that's how people are meeting.
You have to be on the apps, if you're gonna meet people now
especially during quarantine,
during all of this time, that's how it's working.
And you got to know things like,
are you okay with letting your dog kiss your face?
That's something you wanna know?
Or would you rather watch a true crime documentary
or Ninety Day fiance?
The answer to that question,
even though there is some true crime in Ninety Day Fiance,
if you watch, but the answer to that question is vital.
You gotta know.
I won't dislike you,
if you're into something I'm not,
you could expand my horizons and vice versa.
All right, hey, but how about this?
Finally, it's the news that makes our tongues
go ting-aling-aling.
(Drew laughs)
It's the food news.
Num, num, num.
And today we have a food challenge of epic proportions
but three feet to be exact it's fruit roll-up challenge
distractify reports,
this food feat is heating up on TikTok.
Everyone's doing it.
The rules are simple.
You know, those fruit by the foot.
Well, we have those, we're going to unravel them right here.
And then you put one end in your mouth
and without using our hands, we see who can gobble it
down fastest and Drew and I are going to do this right now.
Look here, we have it.
I don't know what the best strategy is.
I don't know, I've never done this.
Okay, well we need you all to root us on, okay.
Alright, ready, set, fruit.
(crew cheering)
Oh my gosh it's so hard.
It is very hard.
Don't make me laugh.
It's so hard.
(bell rings)
Oh this it's really hard.
It's really hard.
(inaudible)
It was harder than it looked.
(bright upbeat sound)